how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe we only have three
episodes of wanda vision left the hype
is definitely real at this point and
in the middle of all of this hype we've
had some big news come out about
spider-man 3.
now we were supposed to get our first
look at spider-man 3
before the end of 2020 we were supposed
to get it in december
2020 and that was according to an actual
sony executive
however of course as we all know that
didn't happen and it looks like we have
figured out why
and it looks like the reason of why they
didn't show us our first look or teaser
by the end of the year has been fixed
and it looks like we could be getting an
official announcement from a major trade
source or
maybe sony or marvel themselves pretty
soon we also have some pretty big black
widow news coming from marvel studios
president kevin feige himself on whether
or not black widow is going to have a
theatrical release a disney plus release
or both at the same time so let's talk
about all the news that happened
over the weekend and of course if you
love marvel and want to stay up to date
on things like spider-man and wanda
vision be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest videos
so over the weekend we had two major
scoopers who have been right about
many different things in the past
seemingly confirmed that some big news
is going to be coming from marvel
relatively soon
these two people are charles murphy and
daniel richmond
now daniel richmond has reported a few
times that sony and
marvel and toby mcguire hadn't exactly
come to a deal
toby maguire wanted to come back for
spider-man 3.
sony and marvel wanted him to come back
as well obviously for the spider-verse
with andrew garfield and tom holland but
they had never reached an
actual agreement they never had an
actual deal on paper
it was never signed however it looks
like that has changed and a deal has
officially been made
this past thursday night a few hours
right before
wanda vision was about to come out both
charles murphy
and daniel richmond tweeted about tobey
maguire's spider-man
charles tweeted a picture of toby
maguire spider-man and then
alongside that picture a picture of tom
holland spider-man holding his thumbs up
a scene from spider-man far from home
implying that toby
is good to go for spider-man 3. he then
tweeted another picture of what seemed
to be
a cropped confirmation from somebody
saying it's a go
obviously referring to the tobey maguire
picture that he posted just minutes
before
and then daniel richmond not too long
after tweeted out a gif
from tobey maguire spider-man 3 also
seemingly confirming that tobey maguire
is on board for tom holland spider-man 3
and then minutes after that he tweeted
out
it's pizza time which of course can only
be a reference to toby maguire's
spider-man
pizza time daniel richmond was the
person who reported that we didn't get a
teaser from sony or marvel for
spider-man 3 because the deal hadn't
been sided with toby yet and they wanted
to make sure that he was on board before
they made an announcement or did some
type of a teaser for the film
he's the one that reported the problems
and since he is now saying
it's pizza time and charles murphy is
saying it as well
it looks like tobin maguire has
officially signed on for spider-man 3.
and it looks like an official
announcement may be coming sometime soon
now a big trade company may announce
this soon like deadline or variety and
this was hinted at by brandon davis
brandondavis
comicbook.com he said this in a tweet
and then he deleted it which leads us to
believe that perhaps a big trade
is going to announce it relatively soon
another possibility for an official
announcement is that it might actually
come from sony and marvel themselves in
the form
of a teaser again a sony executive told
us that we'd get a teaser by the end of
2020 and we didn't
and if it was in fact due to tobey
maguire not being
officially on board well it looks like
that problem is solved he's
on board now which means they could give
us a teaser now we're actually not sure
as to when exactly he signed all that's
happened is the information that he has
signed has been let out so he could have
actually signed
weeks ago which would actually line up
with an instagram post that tom holland
posted
he posted about two weeks ago a picture
of him and his brother on top of his
shoulder saying
today was easily one of the highlights
of my career for those of you that were
there you know what i'm talking about
and for those of you that weren't
you better buckle up now at this point
we widely believe that he was referring
to filming with toby maguire and andrew
garfield and since we now have word that
toby has indeed signed
this is more likely the case this is
what he is most likely referring to and
if it is true that means that the three
spider-men have been filming together
for a couple of weeks now and that's a
decent amount of time and probably a
decent amount of footage to give us some
sort of a teaser
and i'm not talking about a full-on
teaser trailer
something that's like a minute long two
minutes long i don't think that we're
going to get that but at this point in
time
when we were with spider-man far from
home they had already revealed the title
sony and marvel hasn't revealed anything
about spider-man homecoming 3 yet and
that
could be due to the fact that the title
might actually give away the
spider-verse
so there should be some type of teaser
coming soon whether that's just
revealing the title
or revealing a quick little snippet of 3
spider-man or maybe even just
a photo of the three spider-man together
whatever it may be we are definitely
overdue for that teaser that was
promised to us and now it seems like
sony and marvel have everything in place
that they need to actually give us that
teaser
and based off of all these tweets from
these insiders it looks like an official
announcement could be coming very soon
now for all the black widow fans out
there it does look like we have a bit of
new information
black widow has been delayed multiple
times black widow was supposed to be the
first movie coming out in marvel's phase
four followed by the falcon and the
winter soldier the eternals and shang
chi
then after that won division but of
course they all got pushed back and
black widow was the first marvel phase
four project to release
and now black widow isn't coming until
may this year
but that may not actually be the case
anymore there have been a lot of rumors
going around about black widow possibly
going straight to disney plus
disney did this with mulan and they did
it with seoul as well
and it was relatively successful for
both movies now it wasn't the same as
having a huge box office opening
but we're in a pandemic right now and
people aren't really going to the
theaters so there was a lot of talk that
disney was going to do this for black
widow as well
and then wonder woman 1984 was released
in theaters and on hbo
max simultaneously and this got people
wondering if they were going to do this
for black widow as well do a theatrical
release but also release it at the same
time on disney plus
well we now have some official news
about this as kevin feige the president
of marvel studios has spoken up about
how he feels
about a theatrical release and a disney
plus release at the same time
and kevin feige is not for it he is
still pushing for a theatrical release
he is not fond of doing both the
theatrical release and a disney plus
release at the same time
so it's not very likely to happen it
also means that getting black widow on
disney plus
first is probably not going to happen as
well if he doesn't want them to release
in theaters and disney plus
at the same time because he's pushing
for a theatrical release that means he's
not
probably open to a disney plus only
release which unfortunately according to
a report from variety means that black
widow might get delayed
again we've already had a couple of
delays and marvel's phase 4 schedule has
already shifted
a ton but fortunately i don't think that
what happens in black widow will have
that big of an effect or connection to
what happens in all of the other movies
after all it does take place before
avengers end game and i'm sure it sets
up some things that are going to happen
in the future
but if black widow is out of order with
marvel's phase 4 i don't really think
it's going to affect the continuity
which means that marvel could delay it
until it is ready for a theatrical
release and that seems to be what kevin
feige would like to do
so don't expect a disney plus release or
a theatrical and disney plus release but
expect a theatrical release for black
widow which i think a lot of people
would say she deserves but be sure to
subscribe so you can keep up to date on
all the latest news concerning black
widow
spider-man 3 one division and everything
relating to the mcu
be sure to let me know your thoughts on
everything in the comments down below
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can always follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
me